[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
he said the only problem is i've watched
a lot of soap operas
and i've seen actors before
he regrets
what he did
and he's paying a price for it he's
paying a price for it today opening
statements from both sides in the alex
jones defamation trial and basketball
star brittany greiner takes the stand in
her own defense against drug charges in
russia plus when i seen the armed men
come in
you know it was specifically for me a
sunday service interrupted when masked
gunman rob a bishop and his wife and
later the parkland school shooter's
disturbing internet search history i'm
going to be a professional school
shooter law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer in texas
opening statements are presented in the
civil trial involving alex jones years
after the infowars hosts made comments
calling the sandy hook school shooting a
hoax
in december of 2012 a gunman killed 20
first grade students and six staff
members at the connecticut school after
the shooting jones told his audience it
was fake and that it was staged with
actors from the government in order to
push gun control measures the families
of eight victims and an fbi agent who
responded to the school have filed
lawsuits against jones saying they've
been harassed and received death threats
from his followers an austin jury will
hear the case to determine what jones
will pay in damages to those who file
the suits the beginning of the trial
comes after months of delays and after
courts in both texas and connecticut
have already found jones liable for
defamation following jones ignoring
several court orders damages have yet to
be awarded in the connecticut cases
jones has since said he believes the
shooting did happen but claims he had a
right to say that it didn't in opening
statements on tuesday the attorney of
four the plaintiffs argued jones lies
cause harm to the to the victims
families
i first want to talk to you about two
rules
here's the first rule you can't
recklessly tell lies about someone
you can't do it
if you do it
and you cause someone damage you're
responsible
this is the second rule
you can't recklessly tell lies about
something important to someone
in this case like the death of their
child
if you do that
you know you're going to cause them harm
you're responsible for that
you're here
because those rules are broken
and they were broken
in a way in which the world has never
seen before this man knew
that the parents of murdered children
were emotionally distressed
outraged grieving
and he looked straight into that camera
and he said the only problem is i've
watched a lot of soap operas
and i've seen actors before
and i know when i'm watching a movie
and i know when i'm watching something
real
jones defense attorney presented their
opening statement saying his client has
already been punished
because of this case
he lost
all his access
to the internet
millions of dollars
canceled
he regrets
what he did
and he's paying a price for it he's
paying a price for it today he pays a
price for it every time somebody on the
street
chases him
and says
you killed the children at sandy hook is
this an honest attempt
by personal injury lawyers
to get just compensation
or
is this a cynical
attempt by personal injury lawyers
to enrich themselves
while silencing
a political opponent
and limiting
every american's right
to choose what they watch
and what they listen to
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike korovonix and co-host
terry austin mike i get it
not having something to say for your
opening happens to a lot of defense
attorneys but does telling the jury how
much your client lost when the opposing
side are grieving families of a mass
shooter sounds smart to you
that opening was disturbing quite
frankly brian because there are times we
have nothing to work with
but
in that opening
this attorney at one point in time is
saying he's paid his dues
yet he still gets back to the political
aspects of it and that this is trying to
to to to quash someone's first amendment
right and that he suffered enough
because of the money he lost when people
lost children and it just that was a
disturbing opening quite frankly brian
not so much from the money aspect of it
but the fact that he really was
apologizing it seemed but he wasn't
because he basically said that they're
trying to punish him because he has a
right to say what he wants regardless of
the harm he caused i don't think that
helped at all and i think it's going to
be damaging in the punitive damage stage
because i think it may really stir the
jury's emotion as to him not accepting
any responsibility for the words to use
and the hurt he caused now tara i know
our guests can't see you but you're not
in your head there so let's talk about
damages how are they going to be decided
and how will that play out in the
witnesses we expect to see in this case
well as you know in a defamation case
you get both compensatory and punitive
damages we saw that in the depth hurt
trial and here we're seeing that the
attorney is actually asking for a
specific amount he asked for 150 million
the way he calculated it was a little
bit strange if you ask me he said a
dollar for each of the 75 million people
who believe the false information and
then 75 million to compensate the
parents i think he should have just said
150 compensate the parents we'll see
what happens as far as the jury is
concerned though that's creative math
though we'll see how the jury likes you
said uh thinks about that dollar for
every follower so to speak well also in
texas a dallas jury orders spectrum to
pay 7 billion in damages after a
customer was murdered by a field
technician
jurors found charter communications
which also operates as spectrum had
systemic safety failures they say
charter acted negligently when hiring
43-year-old roy holden jr in december of
2019 holden was arrested for the murder
of 83 year old betty thomas a customer
who had issues with her phone line after
helping with her technical issue
investigators say holden returned to
thomas's home the next day and stabbed
her with a utility knife supplied by
spectrum attorneys for thomas's family
say charter got rid of an employee
screening program and hired holden
without verifying his work history they
also say spectrum ignored warning signs
including that holden broke down during
a meeting and told a supervisor he was
not ok charter was also ordered to pay
90 percent of the 375 million dollars of
compensatory damages to thomas's family
still ahead on law and crime daily a
sunday church livestream catches a
robbery on camera
but first basketball star brittany
griner takes the stand amidst her
russian drug trial
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back in news on the other side
of the world the biden administration
has offered a convicted russian arms
dealer in exchange for wnba player
brittany griner just after she took the
stand in her drug smuggling case the
move comes less than three weeks after
griner pled guilty to drug charges after
being caught carrying vape cancers with
cannabis oil while at the moscow airport
in february her attorneys previously
presented a letter from a u.s doctor
recommending griner use medical cannabis
to treat pain while cannabis is illegal
in russia testimony has focused on it
being regarded in other countries as
being for medical use on wednesday
greiner testified that her rights were
not read to her when she was arrested
and said after inspectors found the
cartridges she was instructed to sign
documents not knowing what they meant
and tried to use google translate to
understand them greiner told the court
once again that she did not
intentionally bring the drug into the
country cnn reported wednesday the
president has offered up a russian man
serving a 25-year prison sentence as
part of a potential exchange deal for
griner and paul whelan a u.s man who's
been held for alleged espionage since
2018. if the deal isn't accepted greiner
could face 10 years behind bars
terry is the fact that there may have
been a language barrier in greiner's
arrest going to help her clarify these
charges in a way that could reduce her
sentence or even get her home sooner
you know i think it will help every
little bit of information is going to
help to mitigate this sentence she's
already pleaded guilty and what she's
trying to do now is evoke some sympathy
so she basically explained this was
medical use and it wasn't intentional
she was packing she didn't mean to pack
it and i think saying that she didn't
understand the language and she wasn't
read her rights it makes the court think
okay maybe she didn't understand what
was going on i don't know if at the end
of the day it's going to help hopefully
the deal that we are seeing is in the
making will help but at the end of the
day i think she's doing her best to
evoke some sympathy from that court yeah
now mike
terry's right griner had pled guilty but
it's a little different than in the
states the case is still going forward
in this guilt or innocent phase but the
way it's progressing looks more like a
sentencing hearing where they're trying
to mitigate after pleading guilty so how
does that look so far is what she
testifying to mitigating her guilt
you know it's a it's this is such an
unusual case because
in any place it's you usually get it
even when marijuana was illegal in
states here you got a ticket and moved
on
i really
hate to say this but it looks like that
this is all just a
show for them to decide what they're
going to do politically and quite
frankly justice or rights have nothing
to do with it
they're using her to sort of get some
sort of position to make their country
get what they want from the united
states so i really think this is just a
show and our opinions on justice really
have no bearing because it's not really
going to happen because this how could
she be sitting this long incarcerated if
anybody was paying attention to what the
laws state and people's rights
absolutely and they're looking russia's
looking to get victor bout a russian
arms dealer makes sense considering the
climate we're in right now well thanks
for the input both of you coming up on
law and crime daily a complete recap of
day eight in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial plus a brooklyn
bishop known for his flashy jewelry and
clothes is robbed at gunpoint all while
delivering a sermon
[Music]
welcome back a flashy brooklyn bishop is
robbed mid-sermon as a live stream video
catches it all on camera long crime
network sierra gillespie has the story
yo
yo
all right right right
all right all right
all right
more than one million dollars worth of
jewelry stolen all while a renowned
brooklyn bishop presented his sunday
sermon they
took all of my wife's jury and took all
of my jury
and
and then they left
however
these young men
didn't know that cameras were on the
leaders of tomorrow international
ministries live streams its services and
last sunday was no different as bishop
lamore miller whitehead addressed his
congregation a group of masked gunmen
interrupted
nobody
whitehead detailed the incident on
instagram live captioning the video yes
they robbed me in my church and when i
seen the armed men come in
you know it was specifically for me
um it was specifically for me and um and
of course my wife
and when i see them come into the
sanctuary
with their guns
i told everybody get out everybody just
get out whitehead says three people
armed and wearing all black interrupted
the sunday sermon he says one of the
suspects pointed a gun at his
eight-month-old daughter's face at the
same time all of his wife's jewelry was
taken after that his jewelry was also
stolen
[Music]
whitehead said he chased the suspects
out of the church where they hopped into
a white mercedes-benz vehicle at the
time about 25 congregants were present
whitehead now says churchgoers are
traumatized right everybody i didn't
know if they wanted to shoot
the church up or um if they
were just coming for a robbery the
bishop known for wearing designer
outfits and flashy jewelry says he and
his family were specifically targeted
you know sometimes
you know when you are a known bishop
um
[Music]
you know it's a gift and a curse when
you have some what of a celebrity status
um
it is a gift for the curse you know you
become the
talk of the town the new york police
department received a report on the
incident and says the investigation is
still ongoing reporting for long crime
network i'm sierra
gillespie terry what was your reaction
when you first heard and even saw this
story
well the first thing i thought was look
obviously it's not a good thing when
someone robs a church but i did think to
myself that a minister wouldn't be or
shouldn't be wearing so much gaudy
jewelry jewelry that would attract
someone he's there every day he's
preaching to the congregation
and generally speaking you don't flout
that wealth when you are supposedly
preaching you're supposed to be modest
you're supposed to be unassuming listen
that's no excuse this robbery should not
have occurred but i did think it was a
little odd that he knew he was somewhat
flashy and he continued to act in that
way obviously we should
please i hope we catch these individuals
and it never happens again but it it
that was the first thing that came to my
mind brian that's interesting the
catholic school boy and me and the
lawyers like on a sunday why would you
do this on a sunday of all days he's
live streaming but that's beside the
point mike no rest as of yet but based
on the facts what charges are you seeing
and how much time could these men face
they could be facing significant amount
of time because it's an armed robbery
they're obviously with some videos that
they were had had in their possession
guns and this also was they entered a
public place where there are many people
so these are all also aggravating
factors um i think though if he would
just wear a bow tie he wouldn't need a
million dollars worth of jewelry
well played mike will play him of course
i think he's actually putting out an
offer
for more information about those who are
robbed him so of course look into that
and if you do have information on the
brooklyn bishop being robbed make sure
to contact your local authority well
when we come back the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial what
investigators found in the gunman's
google and youtube search history
welcome back to law and crime daily as
the parkland school shooter trial
reaches day eight the defendant's
actions post arrests are brought to
light
right now a broward county jury is
tasked with determining the fate of the
parkland school shooter because the
shooter pled guilty in october of last
year his only possible sentences are
life in prison or the death penalty the
charge is down from the february 14 2018
shooting at marjory stoneman douglas
high school 17 people were killed and 17
more injured when the then 19 year old
gunman opened fire on wednesday jurors
were shown surveillance video of the
gunman's attack on a jail guard that
happened just eight months after the
shooting massacre
once he's going for my taser
i immediately had to get my taser back
he's going for it right there
with his right hand he also grabs with
his left you can see he's trying to
press the button right there he has the
taser in his right hand
at this point
like i have to get the taser back
he could tase me he can incapacitate me
and he can basically do whatever he
wants to me also
if he hits me with it you know it's a
blunt object he could hurt me
so
all i was thinking right there was get
my taser back the only way the taser
goes off is if you press the trigger at
this point we're fighting for the for
the taser i can't tell you if i press
the trigger or mr cruz
press the trigger but the
the taser deployed
later parents of the victims had an
emotional response when the shooter's
internet history was read aloud
i hide it deep within and think about
killing people
september 18 2017 at 12 42 and 43
seconds am utc
the last part makes me scared what
happens when i have no one i am 18 still
in high school and everyone is on their
way to college while i am there thinking
about killing people and ending their
lives
i hate my life
and i want to take people with me
september 22 2017 at 4 21 45 seconds am
utc
i hate humans
september 24th
2017
11 49 and one second pm utc
i'm going to be a professional school
shooter
mike it's not about the murder i'm going
back to the video that we saw him
fighting the guard but it's pretty bad
for the sentencing
when determining his life or death my
question for you though in this video
could there be a possible appeal because
it's something almost separate from the
mass shooting itself
yes it could be and um although there
are
quite frankly there's much less burdens
of proof in the sentencing phase as
opposed to a trial phase however it will
contribute to showing perhaps that he's
got no likelihood of rehabilitation
however i just think the the
proofs are so strong in this case that
maybe it wasn't worth making an
appellate issue by showing that but i i
don't see that how they would win on
appeal the defense because i do think it
goes to rehabilitation into showing
there's a lack of it yeah
the one point i was raising it could
just add to how long this saga continues
even if he is sentenced to life without
the death penalty or the death penalty
if you add potential appellate issues
there well terry the shooter's comment
made it clear that he has some mental
health issues what more can be done from
a legal perspective though in this case
you know one of the things i think we
need to do there are many things we need
to do ban assault weapons is one of them
but i think in the case of someone who
has mental illness and who has
demonstrated that we do need red flag
logs that work oftentimes these laws
don't work because they are not enforced
it allows family members or law
enforcements or even someone selling a
gun to keep someone from buying or
possessing that gun if they think that
person might be in crisis or might have
a mental health issue the gun can even
be taken away if the person has the
possession of a gun so i think it's
something that we need to make sure
we're enforcing and it does exist these
red flag laws exist in 19 different
states including you know california new
york florida where this shooting
occurred and if we had people who
enforced it more we might have less
shootings
here's to that well thank you mike and
terry and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you